Can you imagine how much easier business could
be if you and I could be in seven different
places at the same time?
Now obviously today we don't have that technology,
so until that happens, we've got to figure
out how to build remotely.
Today in this episode, I will talk to you
about how you can lead multiple teams in multiple
locations and be effective at the same time.
So, let's first start off by looking at this
here.
I'm going to give you two examples.
One, why is it that most entrepreneurs only
do well with businesses that are within 30
yards of them?
What do I mean by this?
You run an office.
Everyone's around you.
It's about 30 yards here, 20 yards this way.
You do the math and it's about 3,000 square
feet.
And we can manage that.
But we have a very hard time building remotely
nationally.
So let's look at the pros and cons of each
one.
Pros of building within 30 yards.
One, lots of control.
So, most entrepreneurs start off being control
freaks, for the most part.
Not everybody, but for the most part, the
whole reason why you become an entrepreneur
is you want to control your destiny and all
these other things.
You also like to control what everybody does,
right?
So the pro is, you get to see everybody.
You get to drive everybody.
You get to see the heartbeat because you're
around everybody so they feel the heartbeat.
You are the heartbeat.
Accountability.
It's easy when somebody's doing something,
asking where they're at.
I can be walking in the hallway, and somebody
walks by and I say, "Hey, where are you at
for today?
What did you do today?"
Quick fix.
There's an issue I can solve that issue right
off the bat.
Sometimes, there's office politics.
There's arguments going on.
There's differences.
There's friction.
If I know it, I can say, "Let's have a quick
30-minute meeting" and that can be solved.
So, quick fix.
Low turnover, because the closer they are
to you, turnover will be typically lower.
However, there's one big con.
The big con is exponential growth, which means
expansion.
So the more you control, whatever you control
more, grows less.
Whatever you control more has less possibility
of exponentially growing and exploding.
And you don't mind doing that in the business,
but you also got to make sure you do it properly
from the beginning, so when it explodes, it's
exploding on the right fundamentals instead
of just exploding without having any kind
of standards and expectation to grow on.
So, now, remote, pros and cons.
Pro, you can scale.
Multiple locations, international, national,
East coast, West coast, mid-west, south, it
doesn't matter.
I can be all over the place.
I can build independent leaders, attract different
personalities, because some people like to
be remotely running their own businesses.
They kind of want to be left alone, so those
personalities, the solopreneurs will be turned
on by this.
The cons - lack of accountability, lack of
emotional connection, boredom, sometimes people
that are working off site, remotely from you,
they get bored because they're not being sold
the vision regularly, so they don't see it
on a daily basis, and they get bored.
And last but not least, low retention.
So you have low turnover is a pro here [30
yards], higher retention.
You have low retention here [remote].
So now, someone could say, Well, Pat, this
is exactly why I prefer doing this [30 yards].
This is exactly why I only want to build within
my vicinity, my office, everyone's close to
me.
I don't want to build remotely.
I will challenge you there and tell you from
my own experience, for the first five years
of my business, I only built within 30 yards.
Because I wanted control.
Because I had to know exactly what everything
was doing.
And then I made adjustments.
I made a lot of mistakes but finally figured
out what things you have to do for this to
go from here [30 yards], to here [remote].
So let me explain to you a solution.
#1, before you open up anyone to be remote,
in another place, always have a two to four
week on the job training, field training,
shadowing, whatever you want to call it.
Have somebody come and watch how everything's
being run.
Have them watch how things being the systems,
the protocols, the sales flow.
Anything that is a skill that can be passed
through somebody else, have them sit through
it.
I used to tell myself, I don't do any behavior
unless if somebody's sitting in that office
with me, to watch exactly what I'm doing.
If I'm making phone calls, I want five people
around me to see how I'm making those sales
calls.
What's the purpose if I'm making the calls
all by myself?
If I'm making a sales presentation, I want
sitting right next to me.
If I'm making a conference call with attorneys
and everybody, then I want somebody sitting
right next to me, or being on the call with
me.
I want as much exposure to be with my team,
because I want to do on the job training.
I want more PBDs out there.
I want more leaders being developed out there,
right?
And the way you do it, there's one thing to
give them a manual and say, Here you go!
Go learn how to sell and go get 'em!
The best way to do it, go get.
. . it's not going to work.
On the job training #1.
#2, build leaders.
Focus on developing leaders.
And the way you build leaders that build remotely,
any remote office or multiple locations that
succeed, anything that succeeds, I guarantee
you it succeeds because there's a leader leading
that.
If there's no leader, it doesn't succeed.
It's always the case.
Always the case.
You take any company that's extremely successful,
it is extremely successful because they've
done a very good job building leaders.
Next, this is the part most people don't want
to do.
Most 30-yard type of leaders, which I call
30-yard type of leaders who are control freaks,
they don't like to go visit other offices.
Because typically this [30-yard] becomes their
priority, which it's supposed to be because
this is your hub, but one of these [remote]
could end up being better than your hub, if
you do quarterly visits.
So I like to go visit quarterly.
The reason why I've always liked quarterly
visits is one, I stay connected to the heartbeat,
two, I'm building relationships, three, I
can see things I need to fix, if there's issues,
if there's challenges that come up, if I go
in a place and I notice there's a leak here
we've got to fix, oh I'm so glad we got here
before this one was going to be.
. . oh, they were having issues financially
in this area.
Oh, they had a terminal issue going on here
with the business that they weren't even using
this that could lead into a ton of complaints
that this could have caused a lot of headaches
later on and I'm so glad I did that.
But it requires quarterly visits.
So someone may say, "Pat, what if I have nine
offices?
What if I have five locations?
What if I have this going on?
What if I have that going on?"
Use the 90/10 rule or the Pareto theory, the
80/20 rule, spend 80% of your time on the
top 20% of performing offices.
And develop them and develop those remote
businesses that show up because you can build
them into stronger leaders who can potentially
develop other locations as well.
Next, two times a year do annual gatherings
and conventions, where everybody comes together.
Say you have four offices.
Four offices all come together twice a year.
Everybody sees everybody.
Because people learn from other offices.
People see what other leaders are doing better
than them.
They're collaborating, they're learning, cross-pollinating,
there's a lot of strong strengths coming together.
And this person wasn't good in this, and this
girl was better at it than him.
He learns from her.
She wasn't good at this, that this guy's very
good at.
They learn from together.
There's a lot of strength that comes out of
that.
Next, weekly accountability calls.
Literally weekly accountability calls where
it could go for 90 minutes.
And this is how the call starts.
So, hey, what'd you do this past week?
The way I like to do accountability calls,
I like to do accountability calls based on
two different behaviors.
One is behavior, one is measurable figures.
Each one of them typically have four things
I want to ask for.
So four behaviors, so could be this week I
sent this many emails.
I made this many calls.
I did this many appointments that are these
types of sales.
I made these many appointments that are this
type of thing.
But I want four activities.
So activity, results.
I brought on board this many employees.
I sold this many of this product.
We did this much in our office in volume and
we did this.
Okay, great.
Four activities and results, on a weekly basis.
We start off with those offices leaders that
are running remotely.
Give me these reports on what they did.
Then I ask what worked for everybody this
week.
Share with the rest of us so we can learn.
We did this at our office.
We did that in our office.
We did this.
Phenomenal.
Next, what would you like to process?
Then we literally for an hour process any
subject they want to process together, so
everyone learns from one another, we address
issues there.
We bring leaders bulletin there.
There's challenges, there's issues were solved,
boom.
Next week again.
A weekly accountability going.
Next, daily reports.
The newer the leader is that's running a remote
office, the more daily reports I want.
The more of a veteran leader this person becomes,
that they're running it independently, I only
need weekly reporting.
But if you're newer, I need daily reporting,
because I don't trust you yet.
I don't know who you are yet.
I don't trust you running the operation all
by yourself yet.
I need daily reporting.
Daily reporting could be the same thing.
How much was your activity, what happened,
what did you learn?
Here's what I did today, bop, bop, bop, bop.
Great, three minute email sent, I know.
And I look at it, okay, cool.
Good, I look, all good.
There's a red sign here, red signal.
Let me call them.
Then I call you up.
then I send you a text.
Hey, you told me this in an email here, what
do you mean by that?
Can you elaborate?
Did you figure out how to do this?
Hey, I think you need to read this book.
I think you need to watch this video.
There's still education going on there.
Following, two times a year, fun trips.
What could be a fun trip?
A fun trip could be a BBQ together.
A fun trip could be I put a contest together,
we're going to go to a cruise.
We're going to go to a trip.
We're going to go Disneyworld.
We're going to go to Disneyland.
We're going to go to, I don't know, a show.
We're going to go to a basketball game, a
sporting event, whatever it is, you put it
twice a year that something fun happens, where
they see you not in business, I'm your boss
you better listen to me.
No, it's just let it loose, let's hang out,
let's talk.
Let's break bread, let's talk.
What's going on?
Tell me about your family.
What's going on with your life?
You do that a couple of times a year.
In order for any, and I've seen this over
the years.
Anybody who does this [remote] very effectively,
anybody who does this typically very, very
effectively, they're very good at accountability,
very good at accountability, which means you're
very good at communication, but they're also
very, very good at creating tools that allows
them to constantly develop and improve.
So tools could be many different things.
It could be an accountability tool.
It could be a communication tool.
It can be a reference tool.
It can be a, you know, document tool.
It can be a tool that tells them how to do
something.
It can be an educational tool.
It can be a Salesforce appointment tool.
There's a lot of tools, note tools, there's
a lot of tools that you can use for everyone
to know what things are doing.
Calendar tools.
But it's got to be tool driven.
Google Docs, there's so many different things
that you can use to make it a tool driven
business.
And last but not least, a solution to build
remotely is a leaders bulletin.
I'm a big fan of leaders bulletin.
I had a staff meeting the other day.
This was two weeks ago.
And it was a very intense meeting.
And this is what the staff meeting was.
I said, I as a CEO, I am useless without numbers.
I don't even exist.
I'm a nobody.
You may as well fire me and send me home if
I don't have reports.
I need reports.
I need figures.
I need trends.
I need 24 months.
I need to know what this thing did vs. last
year.
month.
I need as much reporting as possible.
The more reports I have, the more I can find
leaks, where we're losing money, or this individual
is not running a proper office that they can
fix.
So leaders bulletin or reporting allows you
to make the call to that one person that is
struggling with one area that you can help
tweak.
Or the sales in that office goes back up.
But if you have no leaders bulletin, no reporting,
who the hell am I competing against?
How am I measuring myself to improve?
What am I going to figure out what my prior
best is to beat?
I can't do it.
It's your responsibility as a leader who's
trying to build multiple teams in multiple
locations to have proper reporting, proper
accountability, proper leaders bulletin so
I know how to improve my business.
So, having said that, this kind of gives you
a better idea for those of you guys that cannot
yet duplicate yourself in multiple different
places, and you're a 30-yard type of a leader
to figure out a way to become a remote leader
where you start building remotely and all
of a sudden you have a national business,
possibly even an international business, because
you figured out a way to hold people accountable
and build leaders.
So if you have any questions, any thoughts,
any comments, comment on the bottom.
Paul, let's get our pillow here.
Paul's completely gone, on the other side.
Worst throw of his lifetime here, he did today.
We did the stairs in Santa Monica, so you
should see the way we're walking after doing
the stairs back to back in Santa Monica.
Paul looks like he's got to use the restroom
every step he takes.
But he's going to be fine.
hey, if you haven't subscribed to this channel,
click on the button here.
Notification squad, you guys are rock stars.
If you are not part of the notification squad,
click on the alert button right next to the
subscribe button, and you will also be part
of the notification squad.
Thanks for watching everybody.
Take care.
Bye bye.